europa se blinda ante la nueva cepa de
coronavirus descubierta en reino unido-
y que es hasta 70% más contagiosa cada
vez son más los países que han
suspendido la llegada de vuelos desde
territorio británico al tiempo que otros
han aumentado los controles de viajeros
que llegan de ese país
el congreso de eeuu acordó un paquete de
ayuda por 900.000 millones de dólares
para combatir la crisis generada por la
pandemia de coronavirus tras meses de
negociaciones los demócratas y
republicanos llegaron al pacto que es el
segundo más grande en la historia del
país
tenemos análisis desde washington
miles de brasileños inundaron las playas
de río de janeiro este domingo en el
inicio del verano en el hemisferio sur
la situación encendió las alarmas de las
autoridades locales en las últimas 24
horas el país reportó 25 mil 400 nuevos
positivos
gracias por continuar con nosotros aquí
en france24 soy valentina torres sánchez
ya son alrededor de 30 las naciones que
han suspendido vuelos con reino unido y
otras han aumentado de los controles a
viajeros provenientes de territorio
británico luego de que se identificara
una nueva cepa de coronavirus que es 70%
más contagiosa la situación es
particularmente grave con francia que
además canceló el transporte de
mercancía lo que pone en jaque a las
autoridades y ciudadanos británicos
puede prolongarse podrían escasear los
alimentos frescos que en su gran mayoría
son importados ya se han detectado más
de una decena de contagios de la nueva
variante lo que también llevó a varios
países de américa latina- a sumarse a la
medida bart y aclara calle tiene más
información
la nueva cepa del virus que causa kobe
19 sigue trayendo nuevas restricciones
para los vuelos de reino unido a los
países europeos que cerraron sus
fronteras con los británicos ahora se
suman por lo menos 5 países
latinoamericanos el primero en prohibir
el transporte aéreo fue el salvador
a partir de ahora queda prohibido el
ingreso a nuestro país de cualquier
persona que es vitín erario de vuelo
haya incluido el reino unido- sudáfrica
o que haya estado en alguno de esos dos
países en los últimos 30 días el
gobierno de colombia también suspendió
desde este lunes los vuelos desde y
hacia reino unido- y cualquier persona
que haya estado en suelo británico en
las últimas dos semanas deberá entrar en
cuarentena según el presidente iván
duque estas medidas de nuevo son de
prevención no son para generar ni pánico
ni generar ninguna situación de
preocupación en la ciudadanía en chile-
la restricción será más dura pues además
de cancelar todos los vuelos
provenientes del reino unido también se
prohibirá desde el martes y por lo menos
durante dos semanas la entrada de
cualquier extranjero que haya estado en
ese país mientras que a los chilenos que
hayan estado recientemente en suelo
británico se les impondrá una cuarentena
obligatoria de 14 días
argentina se suma a las prohibiciones y
sólo permitió aterrizar un vuelo que ya
estaba programado para hoy en el
aeropuerto internacional de ezeiza los
pasajeros y la tripulación tendrán una
cuarentena de una semana y perú no sólo
canceló todos los viajes desde reino
unido sino que además evalúa los vuelos
desde ya siembro
vamos a eeuu donde el congreso acordó un
plan de ayuda y estímulo económico de
900.000 millones de dólares para
combatir la crisis generada por la
pandemia del coronavirus el pacto se
logra tras meses de negociaciones en las
que quedaron en evidencia las
diferencias entre los demócratas y
republicanos y ahora tendrá que ser
votado en ambas cámaras para analizar
este tema conectamos con nuestro
corresponsal en la ciudad de washington
cristóbal vázquez buenos dias cristóbal
explíquenos en qué consiste este paquete
de ayudas que es el primero desde abril
y por qué tomó tanto tiempo un acuerdo
entre los legisladores estadounidenses
valentina además este acuerdo se firma
un día antes de que el gobierno de eeuu
hubiera cerrado precisamente por falta
de fondos trump ya firma entonces esta
ley de ayuda económica que incluye 600
dólares de cheques para cada
estadounidense que gane menos de 75 mil
dólares al año incluye también un el
revivir el paquete de ayuda al desempleo
de subsidio al desempleado que le
otorgará entonces al desempleado 300
dólares semanales por 11 semanas irá
también 284 mil millones de dólares en
una línea de crédito a pequeñas empresas
una línea de crédito estaba cerrada
también por falta de fondos el paquete
incluye ayudas también de 15 mil
millones de dólares a teatros y a
centros culturales que se han visto
afectados precisamente por las medidas
sanitarias y pues se demoró tanto
valentina porque demócratas y
republicanos pues primero estaban
enfocados en el tema electoral también
en todas las demandas de fraude que hubo
de parte del presidente trump
y obviamente por temas biológicos
cristóbal pese a que es el segundo
paquete más grande en la historia del
país los demócratas y varios expertos
han asegurado que es insuficiente
si de hecho el paquete inicialmente iba
a ser vall entidad de 14 billones de
dólares sin embargo tras la negociación
termina quedando en cerca de 900 mil
millones de dólares es uno de los
paquetes más grandes de ayuda económica
pero los economistas están diciendo que
no va a ser suficiente teniendo en
cuenta la grave crisis económica y la
cantidad de negocios que han cerrado de
hecho el líder demócrata del senado
shock summers dice que este apenas es un
principio y que se pueden venir nuevos
paquetes de ayuda económica en el futuro
de hecho joe biden el presidente electo
lo dijo también en el pasado y lo ha
repetido varias veces que cuando llegue
a la casa blanca el 20 de enero va a
tratar de avanzar un nuevo paquete de
ayuda económica que superará en este
caso el 1,5 billones de dólares
cristóbal pues muchas gracias por toda
esta información y por los detalles
continuamos en eeuu se prevé que hoy
inicien las inmunizaciones contra el cob
y 19 con la vacuna del laboratorio
moderna esto ocurriría en las próximas
horas
el fármaco se aplicará en 3
700 puntos del país durante esta semana
se trata de la segunda vacuna aprobada
en eeuu y su aplicación está enfocada
principalmente en áreas rurales porque
es mucho más fácil de almacenar que la
inyección de facer y bayonne tec el país
está a la espera de la vacunación del
presidente electo joe biden que está
programada para hoy
vamos a europa porque en las próximas
horas un panel de expertos de la agencia
europea de medicamentos podría autorizar
la vacuna de facer variante contra el
coi 19 de recibir la aprobación se
espera que la comisión europea le dé luz
verde este miércoles y la inmunización
en el bloque inicie el 27 de diciembre
de acuerdo con un documento interno la
unión europea acordó pagar quince cinco
euros por cada dosis de la vacuna
volvemos a américa latina' puntualmente
a brasil pese a ser el segundo país con
más fallecimientos del mundo y de estar
viendo un importante aumento de los
contagios
miles de ciudadanos inundaron las playas
de río de janeiro con pocas mascarillas
a la vista esto el tiempo que la
inmunización masiva se ve demorada por
las luchas políticas internas
como cualquier otro año las playas de
copacabana e ipanema en río de janeiro
estaban llenas el domingo cuando el
hemisferio sur comienza el verano esto
ocurre en un país con la segunda cifra
de muertos por kobe 19 más alta del
mundo brasil registró más de 25.000
nuevos casos y más de 400 muertes el
domingo cerca de 186 mil personas han
muerto desde que comenzó la pandemia en
medio de esto el gobierno lanzó una
campaña la semana pasada para generar
conciencia sobre la vacunación pero el
presidente quien insistentemente ha
dicho que se trata sólo de una pequeña
gripa tiene una visión diferente de la
pandemia realmente está llegando a su
fin las cifras lo demuestran ahora
tenemos un pequeño aumento lo que ellos
llaman un pequeño resurgimiento que es
previsible pero la prisa por la vacuna
no se justifica porque afecta a la vida
de las personas no se justifica porque
ese es el eco de las personas ven
oculares
bolsonaro ha dicho que las dosis eran
gratuitas pero no obligatorias
insistiendo en que él no se vacunará
incluso cuando el supremo tribunal de
brasil decidió que las autoridades
locales pueden hacer de la vacunación un
requisito el presidente de extrema
derecha criticó al laboratorio facer por
solicitar una exención de
responsabilidad por las posibles
contraindicaciones burlándose de que la
vacuna de facer variante podría
convertir a la gente en un cocodrilo o
el súper humanos
fischer astrazéneca jansen y la china
sinovac están esperando la aprobación de
las autoridades de brasil el gobierno
aspira a comenzar la vacunación masiva
en febrero finalizamos en áfrica las
autoridades de república centroafricana
indicaron que rusia y ruanda han enviado
cientos de tropas a ese país luego de
que grupos rebeldes supuestamente
intentarán realizar un golpe de estado a
sólo seis días de las elecciones el
gobierno acusó al ex presidente françois
bozizé de alentar el golpe mientras que
la oposición solicitó el retraso de los
comicios por su parte naciones unidas
indicó que la situación está bajo
control
así concluimos esta emisión recuerden
que pueden ampliar toda la información
en nuestra web france24 puntocom
volvemos en breve
[Música]